[Music]
all that stands between you and a pool
of boiling rotten egg smelling acidic
water is a humble Boardwalk
and your good judgment
stray off the path and you could be
headed toward quite the swim
heads up scorching temperatures would be
just the start of your problems
how long could you survive your
accidental dip
how would it feel to swallow these
colorful Waters
and why might there not be anything left
of you to save
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you fell into a yellow stone
Hot Spring
Yellowstone National Park is one of the
most iconic in the United States and
it's situated atop a volcanic hot spot
if you decided to take an off trail hike
you could accidentally walk right into
Emerald spring
this hot spring is located in the Norris
geyser Basin and it looks spectacular
except you'd notice that the visuals
don't make up for the stench
yeah you'd catch a whiff of what smells
like rotten eggs
that's the result of sulfur-eating
microorganisms that create sulfuric acid
acid evaporates and turns into hydrogen
sulfide gas which gives off a putrid
aroma
get a little closer and you'll be able
to feel that the green waters are hot
sizzling hot
there's no way you'd even want to stick
a toe in them
not be up to you
as you approached the dazzling but
stinky hot spring the ground around it
would seem solid
and then you hear a crack
ground at your feet gave way to your
body weight you were standing on a
delicate crust formed by underground
minerals dissolved by the water and then
redeposited on the surface of the spring
all of this made the crust as thin and
fragile as a sheet of ice
your whole body would be completely
submerged you'd Now understand why the
word hot in Hot Springs is not an
understatement
the Blazing temperatures hitting 82
degrees Celsius in places would send a
sharp pain through your skin that's
dangerously close to water's boiling
point
before contacts temperatures of 50
degrees Celsius can give you third
degree burns in five minutes
if you fell into Emerald spring chances
are you'd be dead in three minutes or
less
now before things get really nasty you
could try to push through the pain and
pull yourself out of this mess
but even then the outcome wouldn't be
pretty
you would end up in a hospital in
critical condition clinging to your life
but if you didn't make it out in time
you'd begin to boil from the inside out
and this would be just the agonizing
start of your very unavoidable demise
you see hydrothermal vents help turn
Emerald spring into a potent Acid Bath
by perpetually infusing it with chemical
microbes on top of that microorganisms
compound the problem by breaking off
pieces of the surrounding Rock and
adding sulfuric acid to the pool all
that makes falling into Emerald spring
the near equivalent of dousing yourself
with hydrochloric acid
when Emerald Springs water touched your
skin
it would cause your tissue to swell and
bubble
if it wasn't for your gurgling you'd be
able to feel the popping of your
exploding blood vessels you'd start to
bleed out
the fat under your skin would also begin
to bubble and with all that screaming
you'd swallow more and more liquid acid
that would burn through your stomach and
destroy your internal organs
if your lifeless body wasn't pulled out
in time all that would remain of you
would be a thick coat of blood fat and
tissue floating on the top of the
emerald green water
after a 23 year old man fell into a hot
spring in the Norris geyser Basin
authorities had to delay retrieving his
body due to a thunderstorm
the next day nothing of the unfortunate
visitor's body remained
urban legend has it that all the
authorities found were his wallet and
flip-flops
sadly he's just one of 22 people known
to have died from hot spring related
injuries in and around Yellowstone since
1890.
in a best case scenario you would end up
in critical care battling third degree
burns
worst case you're dissolved into a fizzy
goo
so follow the park rules and don't
wander off the designated paths
of course that will never guarantee your
safety after all Yellowstone Park does
sit on top of an active super volcano
and it might be ready to erupt any day
now
but that's a story
or another
[Music]